hey what's up guys My Name Is AO and
welcome to episode 100 of game
programming 100 episodes can you guys
believe that crazy crazy stuff so today
we are going to do the AAR search
algorithm from start to finish
completely in this episode no matter how
long it takes us and it's going to take
us a while so what we've got right now
is we've got this node class right so I
want you guys to take a good look at
that if you don't have that already that
was the previous episode and then we
also talked about Vector 2i in another
episode These are the two main class
classes that we're going to use in
conjunction with the AAR search
algorithm to actually get it to um well
to work properly and to work the way
that we want it to work okay so um what
I'm going to do is I'm actually going to
close every other class that we don't
need so we only need level which is
where we will of course implement the
actual algorithm um vector 2i and node
okay so what we're going to do today is
basically just implemented in the sense
of um we're not actually going to do
stuff like like I guess way points and
stuff like that but um and we certainly
won't get mobs to follow those way
points just yet we're we're actually
just going to focus on the actual
algorithm itself and getting it to find
a path now what we do with the path
we'll probably cover in next episode
okay so um in the level class we've got
a bunch of uh methods here that we've
already made such as get players get
entities methods that really um have
have have something to do with level in
the sense that it allows the level to
give us some kind of data since every
entity and that includes the player or
any mob any entity that's in the level
it's it's you know it has to be in the
level right if we actually go to our if
we actually just open our entity uh
class here you'll see that we have an
init right initialized method um that
takes level as a parameter so every time
that we actually add an entity to the
level we have to give the entity a copy
of that level so that we can then use
that level level to manipulate the
entity okay so similarly like this this
is why the AAR search algorithm is going
into um into I guess the level class
it's because
um it is because uh the level is what's
going to you know find the PATH at okay
because the whole the whole point of of
this ay search algorithm is to provide I
guess the entity um or an entity um a
means of getting to another point on on
the level okay so therefore since the
level has all that data that we need
such as any other entities things like
walls things that we can't get through
um that's why the AAR sear search
algorithm is actually going to be inside
this level class now in order to achieve
this um well I guess I'm just going to
start off here I'm probably just going
to go down here into um maybe just above
just below get ju just above get
entities here I'm just going to make a
public list of
nodes and I'll just call this F find
path okay and we're actually going to
take in two parameters okay the vector
uh 2i of where we should
start okay and the vector 2 I where we
should well finish I guess where we want
to end up with our goal okay so what
we're doing is where again with this
method we are going to return a list an
array list of nodes okay nodes being
these things okay not vectors not not an
array list of vectors but an array list
of nodes and nodes have Vector remember
but they also have other important
details here that we'll talk about um
such as a parent primarily here okay so
let's start with this thing right so
let's first of all import Vector since
we need that
stuff okay brilliant so the way that the
AAR search algorithm operates I'm not
going to spend too much on how it
actually works cuz that could take hours
I might I might make an in-depth episode
that really actually like covers it with
diagram and St that if you guys really
want me to do that but um essentially
the way that it works is uh first of all
there are two array lists okay one's
called the open list and uh we'll just
set that equal to new array list uh node
and then we've got another one which is
called the uh the Clos list okay or the
well yeah the closed list okay and I'll
explain what these are in a second
briefly all right so the idea is open
list are all the all like the tiles or
the areas in fact you know let's let's
do this really quickly I'll just uh open
the real quick so I can illustrate this
to you guys so we've got we've got this
game obviously right every tile as we
see it right now is a potential like
place that the uh that the the a search
algorithm can consider when it's working
out a path um so what we need to do here
and what this open and closed list stuff
is is open list is every kind of tile in
this in this instance of course the a
star search algorithm doesn't actually
have to deal with tiles per se but um in
this case it it is uh so every every
tile here that we consider is actually
put into the open list all right and
then what we do is we kind of remove
them one by one from the open list put
them into into the Clos list the Clos
list being don't look at that tile
anymore it's it's been outlawed or
something um but the open list is the
tiles that we're currently considering
and the way that the AAR s algorithm
will actually work is it will consider
all the adjacencies of the tiles in
other words all the neighboring tiles of
a particular tile um and it will put
them into the open list and men will
actually go through each of them if we
need to and find the one that is
actually closest to our goal so for
example if we're trying to get from this
one over here to this one over here then
what we'll do is we'll uh add this one
to the open list we'll actually consider
all the and then then we'll actually put
it into the close list so once we once
we're considering this tile we'll pop it
into the close list and then what what
we'll do is we'll pop each one of these
eight adjacencies into the uh okay we're
ignoring walls here but anyway into the
open list and then we'll consider each
of them and then we'll find okay this
one over here is really close to the
goal so we'll just start off with this
one okay then this one gets moved these
all these other ones will get moved to
the close list and this one continues
it's pretty uh it's pretty complicated
but hopefully you guys will get this in
a minute okay so
anyway um the we also need a way to keep
track of the node that we're currently
considering so I just like to make a
node called current that's the node that
we're currently looking at so in other
words the node that uh that we're up to
I guess in this path we'll set it equal
to new node okay and the reason we're
setting this stuff up is because this is
the very start of our ay search
algorithm so in other words when the
algorithm first starts this is actually
where we're going to this is like the
initialization of it okay so we need a
place to start and that is this
parameter so we'll make a new node with
the vector here being starred if we go
back to our node you can see that our
first parameter here is a vector we also
need a parent now because this is the
beginning to start there is no parent so
we'll simply set that equal to null very
very simple stuff nothing fancy here um
what else do we need so the G cost okay
will be zero well actually pretty much
everything's going to be zero except
actually for the h cost so remember the
G cost is the cost since the start
essentially and we're at the start so
clearly it's going to be zero now this
is where it comes into the H cost okay
and the H cost being the cost from the
start a an estimate from the cost uh an
estimate of the cost from the start to
the Finish okay now to do that we
actually need to Simply find out the
distance between the start and the goal
okay I don't think we've got any methods
here yet no we don't so we'll make a um
we'll make a we should probably make
this private shouldn't
we
yeah you know what we'll do we'll make a
private method here called uh it'll
return a double actually we'll call it
get distance and it's actually just in
charge of getting uh I guess the
distance between two vectors so Vector
2i oh you know what we could do actually
yeah um I think what we could do I'm
just thinking would it be better to put
it into the vector
class so we've already got stuff like
subtract we've got um you know we we
won't confuse ourselves we'll just we'll
just leave it here so uh I guess the the
distance between a tile and um and the
go okay so any kind of tile and the goal
it doesn't have to be a tile just Vector
one vector two I just didn't want to
call them Vector one vector two so we'll
make this is just going to be some
simple simple Pythagoras Theorem here so
math do um oh we don't need that
actually so just it's simply tile dot
oops tile. xus go dox right and then Dy
will be tile. Yus go doy and then of
course we'll just simply return the
square root of that oh well the square
root of both of them squared so DX * DX
which is why we don't need the uh the
math.abs here oh we need to change this
to get X don't don't
we is that yeah okay my
bad and get
Y and get y okay so um that's why we
don't need the absolute value here
because even if this value is negative
it's actually just going to get squared
here which will make it positive anyway
since anything squared is positive um
plus Dy * Dy okay and that's it um so
that will actually just figure out the
distance now why we call it a uh an
estimate I guess or like a horis value
here is because um the reason it's horis
and the reason it's an estimate is
because um we're figuring out the exact
distance so if we're trying to get from
where the player is right now to this
little thing over here there's obviously
a wall in the way now we can't simply be
like oh that's fine you know what the
distance to the Finish will simply be uh
we'll go up here then here then here and
then that's the distance of the finish
we'll just work it out that way well we
can't okay cuz the whole aspect of the a
the the whole reason we're using this
ASR St algorithm is to find the path to
the Finish cuz we don't know it right
now so that's why we can't simply be
like yeah we can find out the direct way
to get to the Finish we can't that's
actually what we're in the process of
figuring out so what we'll do is we'll
actually just we'll guess so we'll say
okay well here's the player right now
there's the Finish we're just going to
draw a straight line and we're going to
figure out that distance that's going to
be our our H cost our guess um all right
so now that we've done that we can
simply type in get distance the two
vectors being start and goal okay that's
it simple as that done okay great so now
what we have to do is uh is add this
current node into the open list so open
list do add
current and that's that's pretty much
all of the initialization code for this
a star search algorithm okay that's it
the next step is going to be actually I
guess working out all this stuff now
because it needs to kind of loop over
itself and check every single tile it
needs to check we use a while loop for
that okay and we we actually keep
checking for a way to get to the Finish
as long as this open list isn't empty so
in other words if uh if open list while
or while rather while openlist do size
right is greater than zero so once well
that's something to look at here um
we'll actually just continue searching
for a path now if all of the tiles that
we add into the open list or all of the
nodes that we it doesn't matter no node
equals tile in our case um any of the
tiles or nodes that we add into our open
list if we if there's if that open list
becomes empty that means there is
actually no path to the finish of course
that happens sometimes right if you've
locked yourself in a room you can't
expect to get out um so that's why we
have we have obviously there is a
scenario in which this wild thing will
finish now that's not the only right
that's not the only exit strategy here
we want to stop looking for a path when
there is no path which is what we've
written here or if we find the PATH
right as soon as we freaking as soon as
we find a way out as soon as we found
the path we want to just return it
straight away okay and what I'll do here
is I'll just say quickly just so we can
get out of this if if
current dot uh so current is our current
node so if our current node and we can
actually uh get our title which is our
Vector do equals um and we'll have to
set up an equals method in a minute but
if it equals goal okay if it equals this
one so if the current if basically if if
the if the place that we're currently
checking is the actual finish then we
essentially need to return here okay and
we'll talk about we'll talk a little a
little about this in the well not in the
next episode but later on in this
episode but not not not just quite now
cuz this is the this is the Finish we're
not up to that yet um Okay so
what we need to do is set the current
tile cuz it's currently there so that's
cool we actually need to set it every
Loop we need to set it
to uh the very first um node in the open
list so in other words we'll just set it
equal to sorry current equals open
list.get 0 okay so that will return the
very first node in this array list now
um in this case of course current we've
we've added current into open list and
then we're setting current equal open
list so get zero it will simply current
will actually equal this current on the
first run but obviously on each
sequential run it won't okay so how do
we Okay so why are we getting the very
first node why are we doing this why
can't we just I don't know why don't we
because obviously let's just say that
we're in the middle of a field we'll get
eight adjacent tiles so why aren't we
getting one of those tiles right why why
specifically number zero why
specifically the very first one well the
reason is what we do
just prior to this is actually sorting
these tiles we'll actually sort out all
of these nodes that are in the open list
that are freshly added that you'll see
in a minute we're actually going to sort
them out in order of closest to furthest
from the Finish okay so in other words
what what we want to do is since AAR is
all about figuring out the closest or
the shortest the lowest cost path to the
Finish we want to consider the tiles
that are Clos to the Finish First and
that's where performance comes into
comes into play we could eventually
check every single tile on the bloody
map and then of course we'd find a good
way but we just want to you know we we
kind of want to give the tiles that are
actually closer to the finish the
priority here so what we need to do is
write a quick comparator that actually
will sort out right we need to we need
to write some kind of sorter that will
actually order all of these tiles uh
from uh I guess the furthest from the
finish the well the shortest of the
Finish to the furthest from the Finish
so that we consider the ones that are
closer first um the way that I'm going
to do that is I'm just going to write a
a private comparator up here so I'll go
to where all of our fields are and what
I'll do here is I'll simply write a
comparator here so in other words it'll
be kind of static here kind of um so
private comparator and the comparator is
all about comparing things right all it
does and we'll we'll actually just make
sure that it deals with nodes
here we'll call this um I guess we just
call this uh node sorter okay we'll sort
out our nodes and we'll set this equal
to new comparator
comparator uh node okay and what we'll
do is we'll actually just straight away
give it a body here um so that we can
deal with this okay let's import this of
course there it is sweet all right and
then if we actually just hover our Mouse
over here we can add the unimplemented
methods which is compare okay so what
compare does here okay and I'll explain
this in a minute cuz this this will look
really weird if you're kind of either
new to Java or you've never used
comparators before cuz they're not you
know they're not very common but
essentially what a comparator does is it
it takes in two uh objects okay so in
this case it's going to take in two node
objects if we change this to integer
it's going to take in two integers it's
going to take in two node objects and
based on what we enter over here it's
either going to return well it's going
to return an integer okay so the way
that we're going to utilizes it utilize
it is we'll uh we'll just call this n0
so node I guess zero node one okay these
are the two nodes that we're comparing
so what we want to do is uh CU this will
be used in conjunction with an array
list and remember an an array list is
just a bunch of indexes so what we want
to do is we want to since we want to
sort it by um I guess okay so since
we're sorting by shortest distance to
the Finish By shortest cost to the
finish what we want to do is we want to
sort it based on the F cost right
because the F cost is actually a
combination of these two and thus it is
our actual like cost right if we just
sort it by G cost or just by H cost
we're not going to get the lowest cost
we're going to get the lowest either
distance from the start distance to the
Finish we don't want to do that okay we
want to get the
shortest uh I guess combination of those
two because that is our that that's our
total cost so since we're sorting by
total cost what we essentially want to
do is we want to check the nodes F cost
and say if it's lower than the other
nodes so in other words if n z is F cost
is lower than n1's F cost we want to
well actually we probably leave them the
same but essentially what we're saying
is if n1's let's just say if n1's F cost
is lower than n Z's F cost switch them
around right and the way we can do that
is simply say if n1f cost what I which
is what I just said is um is actually
less than n Z's F cost so in other words
the cost is less thus the path is
shorter then we can return one okay or
positive one I'll just put a plus here
it doesn't really matter so you guys can
see however if it's the other way around
so if n1's F cost is actually greater we
return a negative one okay and what that
will do otherwise if I guess if they're
the same we'll just return zero so what
this is saying is if n1's F cost is less
than zero then essentially we want to
move it up in the index of the array
otherwise we want to move it down okay
that's how this works okay it's pretty
simple so hopefully you guys understood
that I know I talked a lot so now that
we've made this comparator it's not in
use obviously we've just made a way to I
guess compare two things so in other
words we either uh we based on what
we're comparing here where we're either
returning positive one or negative one
which is I guess the direction in the
array which we want to move this node to
so now what we want to do first up is
actually sort this so so luckily in
collections which is the Java class of
course we have a um an an awesome oops
we have an awesome um method here it's
actually static called sort okay and it
takes in a list as an argument here so
in other words we will sort our open
list and the other argument is a
comparator which is what we've just
written so node
Sorter and that's it so it's going to
sort our open list based on what we've
specified in the node sorter which is
you know move the uh move the node
further back if it has a higher f- cost
and move it closer to the front if it
has a lower f- cost and that will sort
it in order from lowest f- cost to
highest F cost which will ensure that
that the that the nodes that we check
first this is going to be such a long
video the nodes that we check first will
actually be the ones that um are closer
or more
efficient all right great so let's uh
let's move on so we've done this we've
done these two this is great and this is
what this is our if we've reached the
finished return
it but if we haven't we'll obviously
continue here so what we'll do is we'll
actually remove so open list
dot uh remove the
current so in other words what we're
doing here and we'll actually just add
it to close this still explain this in a
minute so what we're doing here is we're
actually just
moving the current node from the open
list to the Clos list Okay so we've
checked it right now current is this if
current equals gold great if not then
let's remove it from the open list cuz
we don't we don't want to look at this
tile again we want to move it to the
close list okay so these are the tiles
that we've already checked okay
wonderful and now this is where the real
magic starts we check every single
adjacency and adjacency is of course a
directly connected tile so there are
eight okay I'm sure I didn't need to
bust out paint.net here and show you
guys but if we have let's just quickly
go ahead and change the canvas size here
to let's just go ahead and say 24x 24
and then I'll quickly make make a grid
for you guys uh that is 8 pixels um here
all right so now that we've got this
we've got these tiles here right so if
the one if our current node here okay
our current node that is now in the Clos
list but that's all right it doesn't
matter what list it's in right now we're
still it's still our current uh variable
here if uh if if this is our current one
that we're checking right here this is
the current one um the adjacent ones are
of course going to be these okay okay so
it's going to check every one of these
and it's going to see if they're close
to the Finish or not now very very
important as it checks all of these
adjacent nodes adjacent tiles in this
case um doesn't matter again node equals
tile I want you guys to uh not not in
every circumstance but in our one node
equals tile um as it's going to check
all these it needs to somehow not you
know not all them are going to be valid
so if we happen to have a wall in the
way all right if if this happens to be a
um a wall here then we don't want we
obviously don't want to add that into
the open list because we don't want to
consider it we can't go through a wall
we can't go through a wall what's the
point of considering that um and also we
definitely don't want to add um I guess
we don't want to add it if it's already
been in the Clos list so if if we've
just come from here this is this is the
previous check right this is this is
where we were the previous iteration of
this while loop if we've just come from
here and we've kind of
just moved up in the world this way this
is where we come from that that is an
arrow uh that's an arrow yeah if we've
come from here then we really probably
don't want to check this one again why
we've just come from there that's stupid
so don't check this one either so the
two things that we kind of need to
ignore are tiles that are invalid and
tiles that we've already visited that's
why we add these tiles into the Clos
list so that we avoid looking at them
again um so so what we want to do here
then is first of all we need to set up a
for Loop so four oh and the other one we
don't want to check is the middle cuz
we're there right now so that's
important so for in I equal 0 uh
actually yeah we'll just do I is less
than 9 I
++ so what this will do we could also do
two we could also do a nested for but
I'm pretty sure this is simple enough um
so in other words for each of these
adjacentes cuz remember there's there's
nine total tiles here okay a few of them
we we don't we don't want to actually
visit so in other words actually the one
in the middle here right we want to skip
that straight away so if we look at how
the full Loop's going to pick this up
it's going to go ahead and go um you
know this is going to be zero that's
going to be one that's going to be two
that's going to be three that's going to
be four okay so four index four is the
middle so if I is equal to 4 will
continue okay so we don't we don't even
want to hear about that because we're on
there right now that's we don't want to
add that we don't want to consider that
one cuz we're there right now if it was
the Finish then we' already be there
okay so now we've done this let's get
the current uh location where we're at
so in X is going to be the current.
tile. X get
X actually yes wait oh we might get oh
okay we did we did private them okay no
problem um so we'll get the X this is
the vector and we'll also get the Y so
this is the current location of where we
are right now we'll get the Y um we'll
also get the uh I guess uh what I call
this the direction kind of okay so well
it is the direction but
um uh there's no okay well this is kind
of like the X Direction I'll just call
it x i but I so I mod 3 - one okay so
what this will do is this will be either
NE 1 0 or 1 okay um and same with Y Okay
so so in other words we'll use divided
by for y of course this is a standard
kind of grid uh horizontal vertical
thing we'll call this Yi so what this
will be is over here this is uh becoming
quite let me just um kind of clear this
I
guess just get rid of this stuff kind
of okay cool clear this board okay so
over
here if we are over here then uh X will
be 1 and y will be NE 1 in this quadrant
here if we're over here x will be zero
since we're zero y will still be- 1 okay
so it's relative to the center 0 0 this
is 0 comma 0 right in the center here
this is-1 for X 0 and positive 1 for X
positive 1 for X positive 1 for X since
X is horizontal 0 for X 0 for x and um
let me just draw a better
zero there we go probably get rid of
these as well no okay this is not about
drawing zeros um and this is negative 1
okay and that's obviously uh that's
negative 1 for X okay but for y since
looks like a four but for y since we're
going up and down with Y it's vertical
this will be a -1 for y this will be a
zero for y and this will be a positive
one for y so in other words what we're
doing is we're picking out the direction
since we're dealing with tile precision
and not pixel Precision if we want to
move one tile to the left so in other
words since we're considering all of
these neighbors all these adjacencies if
we want to consider the one tile that's
to our left we can simply grab the
current X position of the current tile
and subtract one from it and then that
will actually land us onto this tile
that we can now that we can now look at
so this is a way to I guess select the
current neighbor that we're checking out
the current adjacency that we're
checking out so now that we've got these
values here we simply want to grab the
uh the current tile that we're at I'm
just going to call this at okay this is
the tile that we're looking at right now
um that we're considering currently in
this current iteration of this for Loop
so get tile x + x i y + y i okay and of
course X is our current tile and then x
i is either - 1 1 or positive 1
depending on the iteration of this for
Loop same with y y is either negative 1
Z or positive 1 okay so in other words
this will make sure that this at thing
will actually be every single tile in
this list except for the middle CU we
ski that over here
right it'll be every single one at one
point so we'll consider all of these
surrounding tiles um so first of all if
add equals null if we're somehow gotten
out of the map or we couldn't actually
get the tile the at the particular
location you'll actually notice that
we're using the get tile method which
simply Returns the tile based on the uh
um I guess the uh the tile coordinate
here so um I guess that's useful just to
note that we'll continue okay so now
that we're not null we can actually do
something so we'll check it out and
we'll say if if at is solid right then
it's useless to us it's a wall we can't
go there anyway so what's the point of
considering this
continue okay so the reason we haven't
put this into one statement by the way
is because if at is uh is actually null
and we consider this solid thing uh
that's a null pointer exception so it'll
crash but um this way we check that it's
null first and if it's not null we can
proceed um so if it's solid we'll we'll
skip it so now that we now that it's not
null and it's not solid it's a valid
tile for us right but is it the most
efficient tile is it a tile that we
haven't visited yet is it a viable tile
right it's valid but is it is it
actually viable for us so we'll create a
new Vector 2i I'll just call this a okay
this is literally the the at tile but as
a vector so new Vector 2i uh X Plus x i
so exactly the same thing as this right
it's this tile but in Vector form y +
Yi
okay and then we'll figure out the G
cost for it we'll actually have to
figure out well both the G cost and the
H cost so uh our G cost is very simple
our G cost is simply the current G cost
which for the first iteration will be
zero plus uh the
distance of the tile that we've just
been at so the current
tile and the tile that we're considering
so this is the this is the tile that
we've I guess been at this is the tile
where where we are right now and this is
the neighboring tile now the way that
this equation is set up is because we're
simply comparing a distance of one tile
to another directly we're we're never
comparing we are never with this setup
comparing the distance of here to here
or here to here never we're only
comparing immediate distances like like
I'm just drawing here right now this is
the only kind of distances we're
comparing now the reason that we're
comparing the reason that uh no actually
because we're comparing this kind of
distance it's it's either going to be
positive 1 right which is a distance of
I guess horizontal or vertical or if
it's diagonal since of course diagonal
distances are greater it's going to be
the square < TK of two otherwise known
as around 1.41 okay so that's the way
that's going to work okay but remember
if we've been here okay let's grab
another color blue if we've been here
and we've moved over here and then then
we're moving over here right what it
will do is since we have this current J
cost it'll get the current J cost which
well at the moment I guess if we're up
to this one right here if we're
considering moving to this one it'll
grab the current J cost which is one and
it'll just add on this distance which is
uh < tk2 so it'll be < tk2 + 1 or I
guess two around 2.41 J cost okay that's
how the J cost works and I covered this
previous episode now uh the H cost is of
course uh an estimation from um I guess
our current location to the Finish
so the way that that gets worked out is
um is also really simple it's simply and
we don't need any current stuff remember
it's not like it's not a sum it's not
it's not like a like a a cultive
distance it's just uh the get distance
from a to the Finish which is the goal
really simple stuff that's the age cost
okay that's pretty much it that we're
actually almost done which is awesome
well no because we have to cover the
returning of stuff but we'll do that in
a minute this is quite a special episode
I hope you guys are enjoying I'm almost
out of breath here um so if oh actually
let's first make the node so node node
we'll call it node this is the node that
that we've made out of this data now
because remember a node requires a g
cost and an H cost as well as a vector
so we've done everything it also needs a
parent which is well viable now so new
node uh with of course this Vector here
um uh the parent okay so the parent is
the current uh node that we're comparing
very simple stuff so it is a node we
need a node for the parent and the node
is where we're at right now so in other
words what happens here is since we've
gone through this everything checks out
this seems legit uh we might consider
now moving from let's just say we were
here to uh well I guess to here since
we've already done that yeah what it's
going to do is it's going to parent it's
going to grab this as the parent of this
node because that's where we were last
very simple okay um and uh we also need
the G cost and the H cost and that's it
we've made a Noe if we've successed
successfully made a node out of this
great so what we'll do now is we will
um well we'll add it to the open list
but we should check a few things first
so if it's already in the Clos list
right then we don't want to add it into
the open list okay so if we've already
been there now we have to check have we
already been in this thing so the way
that I like to do this is um because
we're we're not we're not checking we
okay okay so we could have done
something like uh if open if closed list
do uh contains and then you know we
obviously need to go with a node so like
node but that's not what we're comparing
we're simply comparing if the vector is
in the list okay so in other words if
this a vector is in the list not the
entire node so we can't use this okay so
what we have to do is write our own
method here so what I'll do is I'll make
a PR
bulling called V in
list this will check if a vector is in a
list of
nodes so it'll take two
parameters uh well I guess list one oh
no yeah just the list that we're looking
looking for it in and the actual Vector
that we're checking to see if it is in
the list or not okay and this is really
simple so for every node in the list um
I could write a write a normal uh full
loop but I'll probably just going to go
ahead and write a 4H Loop so for I
usually don't do this cuz this sometimes
causes problems but it weren't in this
case um so in other words for every
single node right for every single node
in this list and we'll call it n
um uh if n so that's the node that we're
currently looking at in this list since
We're looping through every note in
there if n. tile do
equals uh vector and we we will have to
set up that equals method in a minute
cuz it won't work um then we'll return
true otherwise if we've gone through the
the entire list and it's not in there
will return false uh this needs to be
done remind me um not that you guys can
this isn't live but uh anyway so if uh V
in list so if inside the closed list we
have this a
vector then uh well we'll continue but
also oh but no no hang on um it's okay
the a star SE also has one little bit
that I'm not going to go into cuz it
will take too long it has one little
other kind of work where a vector that
was pre uh sorry a um a tile that was
previously marked closed can actually be
reopened if you know if in in some
circumstances if there's really no other
way and uh this suddenly becomes viable
like what seemed unviable is now viable
again um then we can actually uh reopen
it so in other words we'll only skip it
if let me just write this out first no
doj cost okay so continue
okay so continue of course means that
we'll skip this current itation of the
full loop um so in other words if the
vector is already in the Clos list but
the G cost this G cost here is
greater right than this nodes G
cost okay which um well which will which
will actually will which will tell us um
if if it's greater than the G cost here
then um you know this probably should be
current J
cost um if if the if the if this J cost
is greater than the current J cost um
then we'll continue I'll actually have
to check have to double check this math
actually because this might be a bit
wrong but um uh then we'll continue okay
but so in other words it can get
reopened if this is false and I I'll
have to really double check this cuz um
I don't have this written down anyways
I'm just going off the top of my head so
I might have to uh actually test it
which I'll do in the next episode but
um if uh if a vector oh okay this is the
other thing if it's already in the open
list we don't want to add it again we
don't have we don't we don't want to
have a duplicate um node in the in the
open list so if uh the open list does
not contain so in other words if if open
list if this Vector is inside the open
list if that is false so if the vector
is not in the open list
or uh the G cost is um less than current
G cost
uh then we'll add
it okay um no it's not going to be
current I think it is node I think I
think it is node cuz that that that's
not going to make any sense if it was
current um again though I'll I'll I'll
have to double check here because I
don't think that will add up anyway um
remind me to double check this let let's
okay let's let's do the return so um
what this will do let me I kind of skip
through this if if the vector is not in
the Clos list sorry if the vector is in
the Clos list uh then we don't need to
add it again so we'll continue however
if the vector that's fine but if the
vector unrelated here if the vector is
not in the open list so if we've never
actually well if it's not in there right
now if it's not if if it if it is in the
closed list we're not going to add it if
it's not in the open list then we will
add it okay so we don't want to add it
we don't we obviously don't want to have
duplicate nodes but on the other hand
and um if it if it's not in the list we
will add it because we're going to
consider it next okay so what this will
do is essentially give us a but it it
won't only add one node we'll actually
get about four but remember once it does
this it's going to finish once it once
it finishes all the adjacencies it's
going to finish this entire for Loop and
then it's going to finish the Y Loop so
it's going to go back to the start and
then it's going to sort them and then
it's only going to consider the one with
the lowest cost so
although we might add like four or even
technically up to eight nodes into the
open list we're only going to look at
the one with the lowest
cost okay so let's talk about returning
this so what we have to do now is
reconstruct the path okay we found the
Finish we need to reconstruct the path
because we need to somehow well that's
the that's the whole point we need to
return an array list of nodes which will
guide us to the finish so we'll create
an array list of nodes I'll call this
one path this is what we're actually
returning this is the the result um new
ril list
path so
while um whoops so while uh the parent
of the current okay so the current is
still being considered here because
remember the current right now is the
Finish since we're in here so if current
dot
uh uh parent so if the parent of the
current one is not null now this is
important um the only circumstance in
which the parent is null is on the
starting tile it's where we've started
so this basically what this will do is
we're retracing our Steps From The
Finish to the start so in other words
keep on looping through this until we
reach the start because we know that
when we do reach the start parent will
be null so um we'll add the
current uh tile to the pathway and then
of course we need to back trace it so we
need to go to the previous tile the way
we do that is we simply Set current
equal to current.
parent because parent stores the
previous tile that we've been at
um
right I've clearly screw something up
here whoops my bad okay so that's that's
what it's going to do so it's going to
actually loop back through all these and
as it goes back to the start it's going
to add all of the all of the nodes that
it visits to this path and now we simply
have to return the path I also want to
clear both of these lists from
memory first because sometimes garbage
collector isn't Creed that and then
we'll simply return this path that we've
reconstructed and that's it okay that is
the AAR search algorithm completed I
will have to double check these again
but um roughly completed okay so the
other thing is um what was the other
thing we wanted yes the equals so n.
tile. equals equals of course right now
if we hover our Mouse here is a is an
object um it's an object uh I guess
method right we want to override that
though because we want to write write
our own equals method because um the
object one will check every single piece
of the object and that's not what that's
not what we want to do we only want to
check if essentially because a vector as
far as we're concerned a vector is only
consistent of an X and Y Valu so we just
need to check if those values are equal
okay um so the way we can do that is
we'll just go back to we'll go back here
into Vector to
um and we down here at the very bottom
we will just make a public uh bulling
equals and we'll have to fit in object
object so we're
overwriting uh the object one so you'll
see over here hopefully let me just uh
return well return false that'll be the
default of course so we'll just write
that in you should see e clipse tells
you that this is actually overwriting
the object thing and if we click on that
okay I don't know this Source attached
but um the object class in Java which
every single class inherits the object
class in Java has a method called Equals
and we're just overwriting it here okay
great so first of all this is really
simple this is really simple so first of
all if um if the object here that we're
looking at is not even an instance of a
vector uh instance of vector 2i so if
this object that we're considering is
not even an instance of this class then
well it's clearly not going to be equal
so let's just return false straight away
don't even don't even like don't even we
don't even need it okay now we need to
cast it so vector 2i v what's call V
equals uh Vector
2i object so now what we're doing is
we're saying that okay here we're
checking to see if this object is
actually a vector if it's not return
false if clearly this doesn't return
that means that it is a vector so since
it's a vector let's just make sure that
we treat it as a vector here um and then
we'll simply go ahead and check if
Vector
dox uh we'll actually use um get X so if
vector. get X is equal to this.g X okay
and we could have just not used this but
anyway um and uh v.g Y is equal to this.
get y then we'll return true so what
we've done here of course is we've
simply compare these two components of
the vector and if they're identical oops
if they're ident IAL then they are the
same we'll return true otherwise if
they're not we'll just return false okay
and that's it so we we've written our
own equals method to override the the
the Java one because uh this is
obviously going to be correct and the
Java one won't be not for this uh case
anyway okay great so one last thing we
need to do since this gives us an error
is return the I guess the default result
so in other words if no path was found
in this entire while loop we will simply
have to return null
okay and that's it all right and we'll
actually okay open list will already be
clear we'll close list do clear open
list will already be clear because the
only reason we get out of this while
loop is if the size of open list is uh
is lessons or is zero okay and if it's
zero it's empty already so no point
cleaning it no point clearing it okay
that's it guys that is the AAR search
algorithm in all its Glory I hope I
explained it well I may do an in-depth
episode it's pretty complicated kind of
it's really it's I don't know it's
depending on what mood you're in how
complicated it is
honestly um but uh if you guys have any
yeah if you guys know what's up with
this cuz uh yeah I'm I'll have to double
check um a few implementations I'll
probably test itest test this out to see
how it works but um drop a comment below
of course if you know if you know what's
up with that but anyway guys I hope you
enjoyed 100 episodes of this series this
is by far probably this is probably the
longest thing I've ever done in my life
in terms of commit commit commitment
wise can't even talk off this thing um
cuz I mean what is it like it's been
it's been a year it's been over a year
it's been like a year and I think two
months uh that I've been doing this for
this this game programming Series so um
it's been a while yeah and I hope you
guys enjoyed all 100 episodes and uh
here's to 100 more cuz that's probably
how long it's going to take if not more
but I think it'll get a lot more fun
very very fast after we finish all this
kind of boilerplate game logic code and
we can move into gameplay design so and
things like multiplayer and actually
more testing I guess than coding it'll
it'll get a lot more fun and it'll just
be an awesome change of pace I think
anyway here's to a 45 minute episode
probably never again this is more of a
3D game programming thing to do but I'll
see you guys next time please hit the
like button if you guys enjoyed this
video cuz um obviously I put a lot of
effort into this and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye
[Music]
bye